what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champions
things are really crazy at barcelona
right now but
i'm not one to panic hey did you call me
every team needs an identity mine is
premier league where are they now
people keep saying my problem is that i
overthink things but
have they considered that they're not
thinking about things enough
england is so different from germany but
at least the food is still bad
[Music]
come on microchip i know you're in there
somewhere
ever since leaving liverpool people act
like i just walked off the edge of the
flat earth
but i am still the best defender of the
truth you see that
the dome is fake it's a projection
created by bill gates to control us
exhibit ah
well oh
what is this they smell like a dutch
medal full of tulips
oh yeah
virgil you're supposed to be injured
[Music]
oh this is impossible can i help you
dejan oh
so sorry i was uh looking for masala i
miss him so bad
cool anyways good luck with that
hey uh you were running pretty fast in
there huh i guess
i mean i'm just rehabbing and you didn't
even break a sweat
i never do he can't be human he sprints
with the bad acls doesn't sweat and
still smells like a springtime in
holland
there's something stinky going on and
i'm gonna stick my nose in it
[Music]
now this is a very good string map
[Music]
[Music]
clones you shouldn't be
here dejon you were transferred
you guys you're not gonna believe it
virgil van dyke is a clone
and there's a whole army of clones in a
secret liverpool laboratory
a livatory or is it like a labra pool oh
come on guys
this is just another one of his cool
cool wacky dude theories
it's true i can prove it it's always
something with this guy
first he said there's a secret fight
club in the basement then gary bell's an
alien and now this you're a liar
and nobody believes you and even if we
did believe you nobody has a vhs player
he has a point right on point
mathematics yes yes
very very questioning things these days
sorry dejean but
maybe it's time to find a new hobby
and then what if i want to convince
these guys
i will need some hard evidence
[Music]
this will do that doesn't belong to you
dejan
get back i'll expose you i'll tell the
whole world what you're doing here
you shouldn't have said that now we
can't let you leave
flank him you'll never
walk alone you'll never walk alone
you'll never walk wait i didn't mean it
i saw nothing come on who am i gonna
tell
nobody believes me anyway right okay
okay i'll never stick my nose where it
doesn't belong again
please i didn't mean it
[Music]
whoa the egg's here are so good
hello comrades it's me dejean lovren the
zenith st petersburg centre-back number
six
after a good night's sleep i now realize
there's no such thing as clones
anyways enjoy your day
um did anyone else know this lovren has
no belly button
yeah he's a weirdo
[Music]
cleaning up after everyone is exhausting
i really need a holiday
when booking my trip i sometimes wonder
what
else could possibly go wrong
i mean that probably won't happen but if
my plans have to change it doesn't
matter because hotels.com has flexible
booking options
hotels.com because just in case
[Music]
is
[Music]
for more vr football like and subscribe
like and subscribe like and subscribe